do you have the numbers to make the
final two that now the question for the
foreign secretary you're gonna make it
into the final two and her rival penny
morden now battling it out for second
place in the tory leadership race
mps will decide tomorrow as today they
whittled the candidates down to the
final trio kami badanok
is eliminated from the election the
remaining three candidates will proceed
to a final ballot of the parliamentary
party
tomorrow morning kami badanok's door for
now shut and her supporters disappointed
what happened i don't know i think some
mp's got cold feet they weren't quite
brave enough to to back him in who do
you think will get into the final two
it's so tight now isn't it between
morden and trust well you you'd be a
forte back against rishi because he's
been the the front runner you know from
day one so he looks like he's got one
one foot in the final it depends now
where uh where chemi's votes go that's
the next question where the hard backers
on the right of the party will break for
liz trust are you more confident now
that liz can get to the final two well
i'm working flat out for liz i'm
confident she can do that we've seen
that momentum building we've seen those
votes and solidly steadily building up
for her throughout all the rounds of
this um
of this contest put on i think 15 votes
in this last round the most of any of
the candidates in terms of a gain
is the foreign secretary a threat to
rishi sunak when it comes to the party
membership this sonic supporter admits
to me she might be who would he fear the
most in the final trussell morden oh
difficult question i think
i think when it comes to the right i
want i want an answer chris all right
well i think sort of rishi versus liz is
going to be the sort of most feared
contest in terms of that will be a
battle for ideas
but for now the battle all about who
replaced this man the outgoing pm
gathering his cabinet for one last time
before the summer break thank you all
very much and uh and let's let's bash on
uh with our agenda but it's not yet
clear whose agenda comes next beth rigby
sky news westminster
well let's get the latest then our chief
political correspondent john craig joins
me now and john everyone's been
crunching the numbers to see where tom
tugan has votes when he went out
yesterday of course now uh kemi baden
ark supporters finding that their phones
are red hot as every vote is chased um
quite an atmosphere there no doubt there
are allegations of dirty tricks tonight
uh anna uh particularly coming from
supporters of uh penny mordent now um
the former uh cabinet minister david
davies who's a rishi sunak uh sorry a
penny morgan supporter alleges that
rishi sunak's a team are what he called
a relocating uh some votes uh from tom
tuggenheart to liz trust because
according to mr davis and mr sunak
believes he can beat the foreign
secretary liz truss in a runoff um he
says rishi has relocated votes he's got
his four or five chief whips that he has
in a boiler room well they're uh for
example mark spencer uh
mark's mark spencer mark harper um and
uh going right back to gavin williamson
there's four or five chief whips as mr
davis says he wants to fight liz because
she's the person will lose the debate
with him um
presumably what rishi thinks is he can
take apart liz's economic patch mr
davis also claims uh that this
leadership campaign is the dirtiest i've
ever seen he says now remember mr davis
uh fought against uh david cameron in uh
in the runoff in 2005. he was also a
candidate in 2001.
um of course there were claims back then
in 2005
uh that david cameron's team lent votes
to david davis because they didn't want
to face
liam fox so these sort of claims are not
new we've heard them before but that's
what we're hearing tonight i mean there
are also claims from uh some of rishi
sunax supporters they find it
inconceivable uh that mr uh
sunak only put on three votes on
yesterday uh when you consider that uh
tom tugginhart uh had 31 votes for being
redistributed now the betting for
tomorrow
is that those
knock votes
59
so roughly 60 will be pretty evenly
split
say 20 20 20 ish between sunak truss and
mordent that would be enough to take uh
mr sunak into the last round take him up
into the 120s possibly
say 128 130 thereabouts but of course it
would be very very close between penny
mordant and liz trust and another twist
her anna earlier today penny morden lost
a vote uh when tobias elwood one of her
supporters and a big critic of boris
johnson was suspended from the tory
party lost the whip for failing to vote
in monday night's confidence vote and uh
supporters of penny mordent are furious
claiming that the
johnson regime wasted no time in
suspending tobias elwood for missing a
vote whereas they held onto and
protected chris pincher who was accused
of sex offenses uh for some time before
eventually suspending him so all around
us tonight dirty tricks allegations
voting is one o'clock till three o'clock
tomorrow results of the final two who'll
go and face the members four o'clock in
the afternoon and by the way it's boris
johnson's final pmq's tomorrow
if he turns up he says he will some
people think he might find it necessary
to go and visit ukraine or somewhere
else